[Music]
get down
i think people hear robot and they think
terminator or robocop your move
creep the idea that you can
build a new organism that has never
existed from cells that does something
we've never seen before essentially a
biological machine
has really captured the imagination if
xenobots sound like science fiction
brought to life
it's because they are they're biological
machines
made by humans but designed by computers
this project offers a new way to make
what you might call a robot that's very
different
from existing robotic technologies a
machine for a new purpose not not to
recapitulate biology
or build a heart but to build something
that could do work
for any number of tasks that you use a
traditional robot for
so it's kind of a weird marriage between
robotics and computer science and
biology
these tiny specks seen here under a
microscope
are xenobots made of about 5 000
living skin cells they get their name
from the african clawed frog
xenopus levus which supplies their cells
they can't reproduce and they will only
live for around 10 days
feeding on the small platelets of yolk
that fill each of their cells
really this was the first time we
thought could you take stem cells and
build something from the ground up
and the idea is really to take these
these stem cells very early in
development
collect them and essentially have
different types of cells like you would
different lego blocks
cells already act like little machines
some contract and expand
others capture material by shaping these
cells
you create the machine so you could
imagine a red lego block is a heart cell
and a green lego block is a skin cell
and then really similar to building
legos where you just sort of
start connecting the pieces from the
bottom up we build our robots in the
same way we just build cell by cell
until we get to a final shape and form
xenobots are designed and then evolve
using artificial intelligence
before they're made sam kriegman is a
graduate
student at the university of vermont and
designed that computer program
unlike every other organism that has
ever existed before
on this planet the xenobots evolved
inside of computer simulations
and the computer simulates the physical
world
but it can do so very rapidly and many
worlds at once
and so it can do evolution in days
instead of millennia and at the end of
this evolutionary process
it prints out a blueprint that tells us
how to build a new organism for some
desired task
from essentially scratch from existing
biological materials
the simulated xenobots are subjected to
physics engines
similar to those in video games the ai
assesses how variants will perform
and makes changes according to the tasks
they're set
this is natural selection put on fast
forward
with a computer at the controls
evolution on earth works as
a long chain of mutations tiny revisions
to existing designs
one after the other over millions or
billions of years
sometimes we can speed this up by
selectively
breeding crops and livestock and dogs
so that their offspring have desired
characteristics
but it's very unlikely that you could
select from wolves or dogs
anything that you wouldn't call a dog
but with
computers we can speed up this process
so we can simulate a billion years of
evolution
in a day or in a week on a supercomputer
the computer selects its top candidates
to build
and only then do humans come back into
the picture
the ai generated blueprints are sent off
to dr blackison
and his wet lab at tufts university
massachusetts
[Music]
right so this is the fun part it's a bit
like sculpting and
some designs are not possible to be
built biologically currently
they have features that are too
difficult to shape or construct like
right angles
very small gaps but we often get five or
six
excellent designs that are completely
buildable in the lab which is where we
poured everything over into the wet lab
and build them by hand manually we then
build from the ground up using those
different cells the shape that we want
and it typically starts as a sphere so
the cells
round off and make a roughly round shape
after 24 hours
and then we go in with a pair of
surgical forceps that we polish
with a sharpening stone manually and
also a very small
cautery electrode we carve away from
that sphere the design and sculpt
the final shape that we would like to
match the computer design
and that's really sort of the amazing
part in the innovation is this the
sculpting aspect
to give you a very very precise
three-dimensional shape
at only the scale of about half of a
millimeter
right now xenobots are made of only
about 5000 skin
and heart muscle cells but they can
perform basic
tasks like moving in a straight line
carrying objects from one spot to
another
and behaving collectively
xenobots don't need to be that
sophisticated to supply some kind of
social utility
we found that even the xenobots that
simply swirl around in their dish
they tended to clean their dish as they
moved through it
so that is they tended spontaneously to
sweep up
and corral any uh detritus in their dish
into centralized neat little piles
why they do that is still somewhat of a
mystery we evolved them
in the computer simulation simply to
move
and we got something for free because
they're living systems
uh that that have their own agenda
and do useful thing things that weren't
necessarily programmed
like cleaning at the moment
all xenobots are constructed out of frog
cells
but if human cells were used instead
then there's huge medical potential for
these machines
potentially they could simply by
swirling around in an
artery scrape plaque off of the walls
or abrade calcium deposits
in arthritic joints with a little bit
more bioengineering we can imagine
targeted drug delivery
which is something that we've been
thinking about even in our very simple
simulations
so when we evolve inside of a computer
uh xenobot to carry a little pellet from
one position
to another target position what that's
getting at is
could these be used to transport
something useful not just a pellet but
a drug or medicine to the precise
location of disease
and so the advantage of using a human
patient's own cells
is that the immune response system uh
wouldn't flush it out
unlike other microorbotic delivery
systems made of metal for example
[Music]
if the production of xenobots which
exists right now
could be scaled up hugely by automating
them with 3d
printers then they could be used to
tackle issues
on a global scale such as pollution
we could imagine without too much
further bioengineering
simply swarms of xenobots that
swirl around and clean could be used
in the environment to clean up little
microscopic
bits of plastic to aggregate them
into a larger ball of plastic that could
be identified
and picked up by traditional robots
boats or drones
and then taken to a recycling center
just wear and tear on robots is awful
difficult so
it's very easy to lose functionality
with small changes especially when
you're dealing with physical motors
it's fairly catastrophic when there's
any sort of damage
but biological systems for millions of
years have been optimized to resist
wear and tear and damage and certainly
amphibians have
many of the same pathways that we humans
do and so
leveraging that's been great it gives us
the ability to have
organisms that when they're damaged can
continue
functioning even with fairly
catastrophic damage so you can
largely bisect the xenobot and it will
zipper itself back up in about five
minutes and continue on doing what it
did before
and this is really amazing we haven't
seen another system that can do
something to that extreme
and blackeston and kriegman believe it's
not just the xenobots that are
revolutionary
but also the supercomputer that's used
to create them
one day it could potentially help humans
redesign themselves
we have super computers that can run
millions of simulations
per minute and it also can be optimized
for whatever we would like so as humans
we often have goals that may be slightly
different than natural selection
and we can now have the computer set up
evolution
and sort of get through this bottleneck
much faster so
you know for example for the heart
perhaps we would like we're seeing that
with
the types of diets that humans eat now
there may be some other type of a heart
valve or
or even some process in the body or
vasculature that's that's superior to
what we humans have
and the computer can likely hone in on
those types of changes very quickly
i think that the point of
the computer simulations isn't just to
speed up
evolution it's that human designers have
really strong biases in the kinds of of
artifacts that we make
so when a human goes to design a robot
they inevitably will copy some familiar
object
the doc the robot will look like a dog
or a human uh or
a plant that they've seen before some
kinds of shapes that that are familiar
to them
now the computer doesn't share our
biases
it might have its own biases um in it
but
it will come up with designs that look
nothing like any organism
or thing that we've seen in the world
and then it's a matter of tackling all
the big ethical and
societal questions about should those be
implemented
how much control should we have over our
bodies and the design of humans
or other organisms these are the same
things that the
plant scientists have been have been
grappling with right it's
it's can you make a bigger tomato can
you make a bigger apple should you
should you make a pesticide resistant
and i think what we're gonna see are
those questions moving into humans very
soon
we're starting small we're using
xenobots but you can extrapolate this on
up so
if a computer is so good at designing a
micro-organism
could a computer design a better horse
could the computer design a better cat
could its computer make something that's
more efficient a better heart for humans
if given the right amount of information
and the right amount of synthetic
evolution
so i think there's a real push to
understand how can ai be harnessed
to really capitalize and even push where
evolution has gotten us to this point
you